what's going on everybody Ian Hart it's
here on behalf of PFF welcome to BR
fantasy football is in the air Thursday
night we got the Dolphins visiting the
Bengals right down the street from me
actually and lovely Cincinnati Dolphins
sitting us three and a half Point
underdogs even though let's be honest
they look like one of the two best teams
in the league right now only the
Dolphins and Eagles still undefeated
after you know 180 minutes of action
we'll see how long that holds and this
is going to be a great game honestly
Thursday Night Football probably
outperforming Sunday and Monday night so
far but looking at some of the specific
matchups in the game one thing that I
think is really going to Define how this
game goes is just can the Bengals slow
down what's really been the sort of
passing offense that we expected to be
residing in Cincinnati not necessarily
Miami so this season to attack of Aloha
Mike McDaniel you know Jalen waddle
Tyree kill whoever you want to give the
most credit to this has been you know
again not the number one passing offense
in the league that honor goes to
Philadelphia Eagles but they really are
number two that's in terms of EPA per
play EPA per pass play PFF passing grade
yards per attempt pick whatever stat you
know is your fancy you're gonna see the
dolphins popping as the number two
offense and it makes sense when you have
all this Talent everywhere being used
the way they are credit to Mike McDaniel
so far this season third and play action
rate and first in shift and motion rate
I mean you just watch the Dolphins play
offense and with so much speed on the
field moving in different directions
It's just tough to have a good feel for
anything I mean there was just a short
touchdown to Jalen waddle on a screen a
couple weeks ago where they had Tyree
killer running back he starts running to
the right and yeah the linebackers have
to take a step that way it's Tyreek Hill
no it's not it's a screen back the other
way at Jalen waddle who gets to walk in
for a score so we do have some you know
banged up players in Miami both Tua and
Jalen waddle expected to play tonight
but listed as questionable on the other
side of things with the Bengals in that
secondary chidobi awuzie very good
cornerback in his own right I think
we've all seen a couple memes about Eli
Apple in these uh you know last few
weeks last few years and especially we
even got tyreik into a talking smack
before the game about Eli so in 4
fortunately Eli Apple question not
questionable but banged up with the
ankle injury I think it's gonna be a
long night for that Bengal secondary I
am happy to take the Dolphins plus three
and a half but great day to be great
either way let's get things started this
is BR fantasy presented by State Farm
thanks for joining us guys I'm Ian
Hardis you know on behalf of PFF joining
you guys each and every Thursday
throughout the season today's topic we
want to talk about the players we should
be selling high on you know they've had
a nice start to the season but it has
only been three weeks let's try to sell
them to some of our friends and get the
players that are really going to be
helping us you know more so throughout
the year and then we also have some
players that we should buy low on
because again it's been three weeks
let's get the good players down the
stretch so guys we're gonna start things
off with Houston Texans running back
Damien Pierce so he's been someone
that's really been ever since August
just kind of shooting up the basically
Fantasy Football World he's someone that
came out of Florida didn't get a lot of
touches but you know it was at your
favorite fantasy football analyst
favorite Prospect because of all the
greater fish numbers he put up in
limited action and he's continued the
great efficiency to a point in terms of
Miss tackles force in terms of yards
after contact Damian Pierce has been
making the most of what he has in
Houston the problem guys as good as
Damian Pierce might be at football the
Houston Texans offense as a whole is
that bad 31st in the EPA per play right
now Rex Burkhead takes the pass down
work and if Rex Burke gets hurt I really
do think Dario gumbawale unfortunately
is going to keep Damian Pierce as an
early down back only so back-to-back
weeks he's been able to flirt with the
15 to 20 carries because the Houston
Texans have rather inexplicably been
able to play with some leads I am not
expecting that to happen this is still
in my opinion the worst team in the
entire NFL and I don't one early down
back inside an offense that is probably
going to have a tough time reaching 20
points during any given week so Damien
Pierce really still has you know some of
that new car smell off him coming from
August and just being the player that
was on everyone's mind he had his best
game of the season last week let's sell
high on him don't be afraid afraid to do
so
appreciate all you guys in the chat
we're gonna have a ton of star sick
questions at the end but I'll also get
to plenty right now from Shelton Shack
he has burrow and Herbert at QB who
should he play this week if Herbert's
gonna give it a go you got to give him a
go always Justin Herbert now it is wild
when you get past these kind of top six
QBs that we've all been talking about
you know for the last few months there
is a clear tier drop-off but at the top
of that I do have Joe burrow so this is
a situation where hey you're feeling
pretty good about yourself with Herbert
and burrow maybe look and try to find a
QB needy roster elsewhere in your league
and flip probably Burl out of the group
from at let's see at 12 pack conference
should I trade lamb for Waller and
McLaren in non-ppr oh I would actually
probably side more towards the city
lambside look we saw the drop last week
like that was not ideal should have been
a nice little 50-yard touchdown added to
his total but everything that we were
hoping to see from CD lamb has been
happening in terms of him just
dominating targets as the clear-cut
number one pass game option in Dallas
the problem is that the target it's
haven't been worth quite as much as we
expected coming from Cooper Rush
compared to Dak Prescott so CD lamb is
someone that I'm not so sure he's going
to have you know the top three top five
finish that some of us were hoping for
just because he is having to deal with
rush a little bit more than Dak with all
due respect to rush he has been playing
some good football again I know CD
hasn't exactly been helping his own
calls all the time but CD lamb still won
those guys where again you can look up
during any given week and see those 15
plus targets when you look at Waller
it's just a situation where he's going
to be the number three option in that
pass game more weeks than not especially
once Hunter Renfro is healthy
from at kpat Stafford or Geno Smith this
week mainstream media refuses to address
how well Geno Smith has been playing
over the past you know really 12 months
even in spot starts last season for
Russell Wilson just putting up
efficiency numbers that if they were
happening from anyone else I think we'd
be talking about it a lot more with that
said still got to go with Matthew
Stafford this week I just think it's a
big tier change and not the easiest
matchup in San Francisco like it is wild
in the year 2022 how Seahawks Lions is
shaping up as a potential you know
shootout of the week but still for me
it's going to be Stafford by a decent
amount and at the Lockwood CH4 Breeze
Hall I like that trade if you're the one
getting Breese hall for sure Clyde
Edward Tulare it's become like a him
versus the world type of thing I
understand he is the number three
overall running back in fantasy right
now maybe a little bit more on that when
we get to you know our sell High guys
later but let's see it's the only
problem guys he literally has played
less snaps than Jared McKinnon this
season Isaiah Pacheco not that big of an
issue but you can see his role is going
to be on early downs and unfortunately
those fantasy friendly goal line
opportunities Cloud Edwards Solaire I
think has just had the perfect mix right
now of scoring touchdowns and getting
some targets but overall just 25th and
expected PPR points per game so it's
very difficult for us to you know
predict the future in terms of talent
much easier in terms of volume in the
actual workloads attached to these guys
unfortunately Clyde just doesn't have I
think his usage is trending downwards
whereas Breece Hall is coming upwards
also want to talk about selling high if
you can this is more of a piece of the
deal but Devonte Parker coming off 156
yards in a game last week I understand
you're probably not going to be able to
find too many suitors you know trying to
sell a house for Devonte Parker but when
you look at that game I don't think
enough credit was being given to the
fact that Jacoby Myers was out with a
knee injury now we lose Mac Jones for
the foreseeable future and even once Mac
Jones comes back taekwon Thornton should
be back from his collarbone injury
before too long so again you know I
understand Devonte Parker isn't going to
be fetching you the goddess offers in
the world but don't be afraid you know
if you're one player away Devonte Parker
you know upgrades someone else's worst
wide receiver on the bench might not be
a bad move from at Leo Angelus should I
trade Barkley or chub for Stefan Diggs
Stefan Diggs yeah absolutely I mean I
think Chubb would probably be the one I
want to go to and it's nothing against
Nick Chubb if you want to say that Nick
chubb's the best running back in the NFL
I will not disagree with you he has four
touchdowns this year he also has four
receptions and unfortunately we've seen
this already if Kareem hunt gets hurt
they will not give Nick chop the
featured role that he really his talents
deserve to have they will unfortunately
bring up the Ernest Johnson and give him
those passed down snaps so right now
Nick Chubb is balling out because the
Browns have the six highest scoring
offense in the NFL I don't expect that
to continue fair play Jacoby Brissette
for you know exceeding expectations so
far again it's one of these things
though we're trying to play the
percentages I do think the Browns are
going down the bill someone with Stefan
Diggs man we can again expect to see
like 15 targets literally any week you
know it comes around
from at Ryan beverage should I try and
sell Cortland Sutton I don't think so
man I think with cortland's son we have
seen him separate himself from Jerry
Judy now I'm not completely out on Judy
either because once again like let's
just we have new information which is
great but we also need to realize that
in this Broncos offense they're like
31st in scoring right now I do an
article every uh Tuesday Monday night at
pff.com you know I call it the sheesh
report basically where I look at drop
touchdowns you know overthrows and
things of that nature and I'm not sure
it's been another offense that's shown
up more often than the Broncos just
getting so close time and time again
from breaking out I understand that you
know we have the funny tweets going out
of you know a bowl of Cheerios with a
banana and they're making fun of the
type of stuff that Russ has been cooking
lately and it has been bad like
objectively terrible from Russ and
Nathaniel Hackett and yet the Broncos
are still in first place in the AFC West
somehow and I do think we'll see bigger
and better days out of them and really
the rest of these offenses and what
should still be a shootout heavy AFC
West
talked about him a couple minutes ago
but another guy I do want to sell high
on right now is Claude Edward Solaire
among all running backs in the NFL right
now she's tied for 39th and Carries he's
tied for 14th and targets and yet he is
the rb3 in real life PPR points for
games so as I said before rb25 and
expected PPR points it's just a matter
of he is going to regress and when we
say regress I'm not saying he's going to
be terrible but he is making the
absolute most out of all of his carries
right now and once he just comes back to
Earth a little bit it's going to be way
more of an rb2 rb3 type of weekly
situation we can live with two RB
backfields in the year 2022. think about
this guys in the year 2019 different
running backs had at least 300 touches
last year four so yeah I'm not saying
that cloudy snap every single touch here
but when Jack McKinnon is taking a lot
the pass down work and then Isaiah
Pacheco maybe even Ronald Jones later in
the season is still buying for some of
the goal line touches there's just not
enough volume to confidently just go
with Cloud over solar so this is the
perfect time to sell how him after he's
gotten some of the good touchdown luck
going on his side don't be afraid to
sell high on Clyde Edward Solaire
another running back we just talked
about is going to have to be Nick Chubb
you know telling you guys to sell the
overall rb2 and the overall rb3 but once
again it just comes down to that volume
and not expecting them to score as many
touchdowns as they have gotten able to
score in the first three weeks of the
season so Nick Chubb again four
touchdowns and four catches through
three games last season though we had
nice splits you know with Kareem Hunt
without Kareem hunt and with Kareem hunt
Nick Chubb averaged 17 and a half
targets and Carries per game without
Kareem hunt 17.6 so I think it's
ridiculous I mean look with all due
respect to the Ernest Johnson you know
former aaf superstar Hall of Famer it's
the Ernest Johnson we're talking about
Nick Chubb here we saw Derrick Henry
catch five passes last week I'm not
trying to say Trump should take Kareem
hunt off the field on passing downs but
the Ernest Johnson Kevin stefanski
smarter man than myself obviously when
it comes to football but unfortunately
trying to play the volume game Nick
Chubb just doesn't do it for me don't be
afraid to sell high on him especially in
full PPR leagues
from at ili Debo for Gabriel Davis and
Kareem hunt I would probably actually
lean towards staying with Debo I know he
didn't see it last week but Jimmy
Garoppolo coming in for Trey Lance hate
to see the injuries for the skill
position players in San Francisco though
having Jimmy G under Center is
objectively good news we just see this
throughout the NFL with heavy mobile
dual threat quarterbacks look at
Baltimore look at Buffalo look at Philly
right now even the running backs have a
really hard time getting going and
unless everything is clicking in the
passing game we usually don't see you
know more than one wide receiver really
going off as well so I think with Debo
is such a unique situation where he is
the team's number one pass game option
and he's also the number two running
back out there on the field so Jimmy G
you know living on those six-inch pop
passes to Debo Samuel somehow those are
counted as a full PPR point you know in
the game that we play so give me Debo
top 10 option the rest of the year
Gabriel Davis already playing her
looking more like a wide receiver three
than a wide receiver too and
unfortunately Kareem Hunt is an injury
away from being someone that ever going
to be vying for the soil production that
we can expect out of Debo each and every
week
from at Scotty Scott Yak Flex Gibson or
Chris alave I'm gonna be going with
Chris olave guys like we talk about the
area he is number one in the NFL in
areas for you guys that don't know air
yards basically they don't matter if no
matter if the pass is completed if James
throws a 50-yard pass in the air to
Chris olave if it's caught for a 75-yard
touchdown it's still 50 air yards
because that's what it traveled in the
air if it's not caught it's still 50 air
yards so it's just a good way of adding
more context to you know stat lines when
we just aren't able to watch every
single play sometime so Chris olave
number one air yards well he's seventh
in the NFL in actual receiving yards as
well so Jameis Winston love them or hate
him the man loves to throw down field 12
yard average Target depth through three
weeks that's easily the highest Mark in
the NFL and I know he's banging up with
the back injury but guess who else is
banged up Michael Thomas and Jarvis
Landry so even if Andy Dalton's going to
be there under Center we can now look at
Chris alape as a weekly double-digit
Target guy and that's an awfully hard
person to keep on the fantasy bench
one final sell High player I want to
talk about is going to be Terry McLaren
I know he let us down a little bit in
the first two weeks he was able to get
you know 100 plus yards last week though
in some garbage time I'm thinking there
still might be some fantasy managers out
there looking at Carson Wentz and
everything this passing game did in the
first two weeks and thinking hey it's
only a matter of time before Terry
mcclorn emerges as the alpha wide
receiver one in the offense but that
whole line of reasoning which was a big
reason why a lot of us drafted Terry
McLaren as early as we did in the
offseason unfortunately we just need to
accept what's happening in this passing
game and that is it's a three-pronged
passing attack Curtis Samuel right now
actually has probably the most fantasy
friendly role of the group because he's
the one getting all the design targets
his average Target theft just 3.3 yards
Terry mccorn 15.3 we've all seen you
know the Carson once experience going on
here one week he actually looks like a
world beater for a little bit the next
week he's taking nine sacks and can
barely move the ball through the air the
entire game so who do you guys think is
going to be more consistent the guy that
Carson has to throw a pass to 3 yards
downfield or the guy that's 15 yards
downfield I'm going to take the three
and it's not just that that's all Curtis
Samuel in the underneath areas of the
field unfortunately McLaren is competing
with Jahan Dotson now they're talented
first round pick who we've seen flash
all over the place to start the year
competed with him for those downfield
opportunities for us to Terry mccorm
fantastic real life player I just don't
think he's the Undisputed number one
that we thought he was he's way more of
a boomer bust wide receiver three not
someone to give away for free but again
if you're able to package these guys
don't be afraid like the one trade offer
we just got Gabriel Davis and Kareem
hunt trading you know two basically b b
plus pieces for that a for that Depot
Samuel for that top 10 wide receiver
running back that's what you should be
looking to do with Terry McLaurin so
selling high on Damien Pierce Devonte
Parker Clyde Edward Solaire Nick Chubb
and Tara mccorm gonna get a couple more
questions before we get to our Buy Low
candidates so from hhi should I trade
Jonathan Taylor
it just depends if you can get someone
to give you know the absolute Kings
ransom for it that's fine I really would
try to get two incredible players in
return for him though just a situation
where he hasn't gotten the touchdowns
yet but similar to you know the Broncos
and everything I talked about Russell
Wilson it's one of those things where I
don't think the Colts offense is going
to be this bad moving forward the rest
of the season literally 31st in EPA per
play right now in Indy and it's been
gross but the Jonathan Taylor usage is
once again everything we could ask for I
mean Frank Reich told us that they
didn't want him leading the NFL and Rush
attempts you know by the time the season
was over it's sure starting to look that
that way that that could be the case
again Naim Heinz really continuing not
to be a factor when they do use him he's
usually out in the slot anyway Jonathan
Taylor continues to be ranked in the top
three if not the top one each and every
week for a reason don't you know sell
low on the guy by any stretch of the
imagination at Tatum Fanboy traded chub
for Kamara and ertz how would I grade
that trade honestly I view chub and
Kamara as fairly entertain changeable
we're going to talk a little more about
Alvin Kamara
um or actually we already did talk about
him earlier in the show just about
someone to not worry about because we
have had James Stone the ball downfield
a bit more than expected and Kamar has
just been injured but last week came
back to his usual role got sniped by
Mark Ingram at the goal line but that
happens to even the best fantasy running
backs out there so I could see Chubb and
Kamara being interchangeable more weeks
than not and Zachary to someone that
just getting fed targets from Kyla
Murray in a Cardinals offense that
doesn't have much many other places to
go with the ball so in my opinion you
got equal value pretty much for the
running backs in a tight end that's
going to continue to be in the top seven
top eight each and every week throughout
the season B plus from your boy Ian all
right guys we are now going to be buying
low on everyone first up
Jaguars running back Travis etn and if
you just groaned good that's my point
that's everyone's attitude towards
Travis etn right now that's why we want
to buy low on him so let's look at the
important things with Travis etn's
offensive environment the Jaguars are a
top seven offense in scoring and the EPA
per play Trevor Lawrence looks like he's
actually pulled you know the Jared Goff
the Peyton Manning where he's good in
year two horrific in year one gets
really good in year two we don't always
see it so far we're seeing what Trevor
Lawrence you know fair play to Christian
Kirk Jose Jones Doug Peterson everyone
that helped make this offense work and
unfortunately like if you had gone back
in August and told everyone this like
hey Lawrence is going to be great this
is going to be a top seven offense and
any efficiency metric you want to look
at etn probably would have been going as
a second round pick instead of the third
or fourth round that he actually was but
we do have James Robinson out there
doing his thing ripping off some big
runs albeit you know some pretty big
holes on those but good job by James
Robinson that's fine though we've had
back to back weeks where the Colts and
Chargers got blown out by the Jaguars
and and I do think the Jaguars are
legitimately good NFL offense now in the
year 2022 I'm not so sure they're going
to be you know winning games by 24 and
28 points during each and every week
these have been the most ideal game
scripts possible for James Robinson over
the past two weeks what happened in week
one when there was a much closer game
etn actually out snapped James Robinson
and what happened there he dropped a
touchdown
sucks and he also got overthrown on a
touchdown so we have seen etn looking
explosive looking like the pass catcher
that he was really born to be I mean
looking at just the numbers so far
DeAndre Swift and Travis etn number one
and number two in yards per reception
this season so Travis etn I get it he
doesn't have the same gaudy week-to-week
ceiling as long as James Robinson stays
healthy but still someone in full PPR
that I think you can put in the flex
maybe even the rb2 spot in the right
match up and feel good about and God
forbid something happens to James
Robinson we're talking about a legit
Workhorse rb1 and Travis etn so don't be
afraid to go get someone where hey yeah
fantasy managers are bummed he's not
what he we thought he could be still has
an awfully High best case scenario for
himself this season
what's up chat from at nacho should I
trade CMC in higbee for Pierce and pits
not even if there's a fire man come on
keep Christian McCaffrey I know he's a
little banged up right now but rap
Sheet's already saying that he should be
out there playing and as much as I do
want to believe that pits is going to
have better days this offense this
passing game it looks like it belongs to
Drake London right now so Kyle Pitts is
someone that when you just look at his
route rate man it's confusing and last
week credit to Arthur Smith for finally
getting him the ball but it really was
it seemed like he went out of his way to
do so in the first half we've now had 10
of 12 quarters for Kyle Pitts where the
usage has not looked good at all so
Tyler Higby on the other hand never
leaves the field he's getting more
targets than we could ever want it pains
me that Tyler Higby could honestly have
a higher fantasy floor than Kyle Pitts
but that's the world we live in so if
the you know Higley pit side of the
equation isn't quite as far in pitts's
favor as we thought I think we all know
that CMC over Pierce is a pretty big win
so no keep CMC keep Pig B hey guys like
Damian Pierce those are the type of
running backs that you see should be
able to go out there and find on the
waiver wire
one more guy I do think you should be
buying low on right now DK Metcalf for
the Seattle Seahawks and don't be afraid
to even wait a week on this one you know
we got a matchup coming up against the
Lions defense that did a fantastic job
shutting down Justin Jefferson last week
they took the number two Corner Jeffrey
acuda had him match up with Jefferson
every single play with help of a second
Defender that's why Adam thielen and KJ
Osborne company were able to go off on
the other side so I do think this could
be a title lock a week but in general
guys look at this Seahawks team I mean
Geno Smith this season 15th and yards
for attempt third and adjust the
completion rate seventh in QB rating
eighth in PFF passing grade the guy's
been a good quarterback maybe an average
Quarterback that's fine we thought he
was gonna be the worst quarterback in
the entire NFL The Way We Were drafting
these wide receivers before the season
started I mean DK Metcalf is someone in
Dynasty Fantasy Football was going as a
top five receiver before the rush trade
happened so the talent's never been in
question we've been worried about the
offense well to the Seahawks credit
they're moving with more Tempo they have
to pass the ball more because they their
defense can't stop anyone right now and
Geno isn't terrible so with all that in
mind we have Metcalf and locket top 20
among wide receivers and targets it just
hasn't quite been going metcalf's way so
I've talked about expected points before
you know in this episode and just
looking at those expected points we take
actually the real PPR points versus the
expected to see who have been the quote
unquote most unlucky players sometimes
they're unlucky sometimes they're not
just they're just bad at football you
know but again with Metcalf I think we
can all agree this is one of the more
talented receivers in the league seventh
most PPR points below expectation for DK
Metcalf the exact solar player we should
be trying to buy at his floor because oh
my goodness guys the ceiling is legit
overall wide receiver one
at Lord bent start Bateman Zay Jones or
Romeo Dobbs gotta be Bateman for me we
did see Zay Jones pop up on the injury
report today with an ankle injury never
want to get those midweek additions to
the crew and with Dobbs it does look
like Christian Watson is going to be
back in the picture after missing last
week with the hamstring injury so I do
love Dobbs you know as a top waiver wire
ad of the week he's a great guy to have
on that roster but we still got Rashad
Bateman going up against a bill
secondary that is just so banged up
right now I mean losing high for the
season tredavius White's still on IR
they just had to go sign old man Xavier
Rhodes off the street to try to add some
sort of depth to this cornerback room so
Rashad Bateman two great first weeks
it's frustrating we're not getting just
more overall targets to him but man with
the way Lamar Jackson's going I will
take his you know number one wide
receiver far more weeks than not
talk a little bit about Alan Robinson
another guy where he's not going to
probably meet the expectations we had
some people were hoping that we could
see the Rams have two top 12 wide
receivers potentially clearly Cooper cup
Matthew staff you know have their own
ways about them and I think we're going
to continue to see cup just mostly
smashing but with Alan Robinson I refuse
to believe that the Rams number two pass
game option is going to continue to be
this disinvolved in the offense you look
out last year the stretched run that obj
had what about Robert Woods remember
this time last year everyone freaking
out about Robert Woods what was he when
he finally got injured the PPR wide
receiver 12 overall so with Alan
Robinson it hasn't been that pretty but
guys if you watch these games he really
has been close very close to having much
more go his way in week two he did score
a touchdown right over the top of AJ
Terrell pretty good cornerback if you
guys have heard and he actually had a
second touchdown in that game that got
nullified not by a penalty but because
the cornerback on the complete other
side of the field was a little wobbly
after maybe getting concussed so the NFL
Replay official had to actually stop to
play even though nobody heard the
whistle so Robinson very nearly had a
two touchdown game in week two
unfortunately he'd drop it would have
been an easy touchdown on week three but
they are going to him on the goal line
Sean McVeigh is a smart guy they need
Alan Robinson more than ever to be that
guy with Van Jefferson on IR I just
think that Alan Robinson right now
someone that most people are starting to
treat as a deep low wide receiver three
maybe even a wide receiver four even if
he doesn't have that top 12 upside this
year I still believe right now you can
acquire a wide receiver for who has a
great chance to be a wide receiver too
sooner rather than later
from at J Keem Khalil Herbert or AJ
Dylan this week Khalil Herbert if Dave
Montgomery is going to be sidelined
otherwise got to go with AJ Dylan this
one shocked me guys Khalil Herbert this
year is averaging 7.3 yards per carry
Justin Fields is averaging 6.6 yards per
pass attempt I know we always scream
about wanting teams to throw more and
stuff but wanting NFL teams to throw
more is always just because in the NFL
with the you know most elite players out
there passing is more efficient than
running it's not like high school and
college in certain situations should
just always be passing more so I don't
mean to compare the two and one maybe
even three and one after this week
Chicago Bears to a high school or
college team but they're running the
ball that well keep doing it I'm not
sure why we would have feel stolen the
ball more when he's not doing that good
of a job of it in the first place
another running back I want to buy low
on though is going to be Josh Jacobs
with the Las Vegas Raiders this one's
interesting I know we had to scare last
week with the sickness going on he did
wind up playing though had a great game
he's looked awesome this whole season
just in terms of my personal eye test
you know how and watched every game Josh
Jacobs one of the better running backs
in the league I think this year with the
football in his hand he's third and
missed tackles Force for Kerry he's
seventh in yards after contact for Kerry
he just hasn't been getting touchdowns
because the Raiders are one of only six
teams without a rushing touchdown yet
now when you look at those six teams
that haven't scored a rushing touchdown
a lot of them haven't been scoring many
touchdowns the Raiders are actually the
League's 10th ranked scoring offense so
it's just been bad luck from Josh Jacobs
he got to the one yard line last week
and they had a fall start so he didn't
have a chance to jam into the end zone
and Devonte Adams scores the next play
the usage has been far better than we
anticipated looking at Las Vegas
I thought this was going to be just New
England Southwest I mean we had Josh
McDaniels just causing all sorts of
headaches for Fantasy managers over the
past decade with Bill Belichick in New
England that's what I figured was going
to look like but no it really hasn't
it's been Josh Jacobs and one of Brandon
Bolton or Amir Abdullah in the pass down
role and that's it two running back
committees as I said before we can live
with two running back committees three
or four when things get complicated so
this season Josh Jacobs tied with Naji
Harris for the ninth most snaps among
running backs he has played more snaps
than Nick Chubb and Seco Elliott Austin
Eckler and Aaron Jones Josh Jacobs has
more expected PPR points than Aaron
Jones Alvin Kamara corduro Patterson and
Clyde Edwards Hilaire again he's playing
great
the volume's great the situation is more
condensed than we thought it was going
to be by Josh Jacobs now before he
inevitably starts finding the end zone
more often inside this top 10 scoring
offense
from at jets4life Kyle Pitts or Tyler
Higby so when we talked about that trade
before I I think it's closer than people
would like to admit but no we still
gotta continue to go with Kyle Pitts
here but come on Arthur Smith like just
keep dialing it up for this guy shout
out to the Falcons offense really I
think just coming past overcoming I
would say our expectations for the
beginning of the year I mean look at an
offense like Kansas City where who can
we really trust in that Patrick Mahomes
Travis Kelsey con and Clyde Edwards
Hilaire for now with the Falcons man
Drake London Kyle Pitts you know coming
on the up and up in corduro Patterson as
well the minimal thing that the Falcons
can do for us is at least condense those
you know targets and those opportunities
around the three best players so far
mostly so good from there still think we
will see bigger days from Kyle Pitts
albeit maybe not meeting that third
round value a lot of us had to pay to
get him on the squad in the first place
finally guys the last group of players I
do want to be buying low on
you know your league mate's better than
me Justin Jefferson Jamar Chase CD Lam
Devonte Adams any of these top wide
receivers that have unfortunately been
disappointing for the better part of the
past two weeks so when we saw week one
these guys look like they would never
have you know under 150 plus yards again
just you know the complete camaraderie
with them in their new situations
usually going off and then you know CD
lamb had the DAC injury and then Devonte
Adams he's been scoring but has him
again in the big yards Justin
Jefferson's getting double teams Jamar
Chase just hasn't been playing his best
football over the past two weeks if you
can find a panic fantasy manager or just
someone willing to trade again one of
the most elite wide receiver fantasy
Assets in the league if you can get them
to trade for let's say you know a mid
low end rb1 someone like Austin Eckler
someone like maybe Ezekiel Elliott if
someone's still falling out on that
that's probably not going to happen but
you know build a trade offer with these
guys don't be afraid to go get one of
these struggling wide receivers who we
still all know has the potential to have
between 150 and 200 targets
all right everyone let's jump into
personalized fantasy advice presented by
State Farm with a personal price plan
it's all about creating a price just for
you at KPS Club CD Lam or Terry McLaren
gotta go with cdlam guys this is a
target Advantage for seaweed right now
is huge I thought Terry was going to be
that guy but just looking at CD this
year 10 plus Targets in every single
game Terry McLaren second on his own
team and targets behind Curtis Samuels
so Carson Wentz versus Cooper Rush maybe
a little bit closer than we thought it
was going to be I will take CD Lam keep
an eye on that McLaren matchup him
versus Trayvon Diggs it's been pretty
fun to watch over the past few years
what is my biggest Fantasy Draft regret
I would say not putting more
not going out of my way more to get
Jalen waddle I mean just the things he's
been able to do this year he demanded so
many targets as a rookie and a dolphins
offense that looked pretty broke and
because of that we didn't see the sort
of big plays from waddle that we had in
Alabama and I think I might have you
know held that against him a little bit
too much I wasn't confident this
Dolphins offense being able to enable
two top 12 fantasy receivers like they
have been able to do so far so waddle
for me I had him ranked you know more so
around guys like Deontay Johnson kind of
in that lower uh wide receiver two range
so not someone I was you know completely
fading by any stretch of the imagination
but trying to I guess look more at the
offensive environment the things that
Mike McDaniel and to be fair to a could
do for him in this offense we had a
player that proved the ability to get
targets at a high rate and make pretty
good use out of him as a rookie the one
thing that I guess I again didn't give
enough credit to was the explosive play
factor that we saw time and time again
at Alabama
from at squido Tua or kylo Murray this
week I'm still sticking with Kyler I
think he's a great option to honestly
buy low as well the Russian just upside
I know Kyle has been running a ton to
start but it's a three-week sample size
guys Tua has never run we have a
lifelong sample size of that even going
back to Alabama Tua doesn't have one
career game with even 50 rushing yards
so what color has it been great but hey
that's a situation where I think Kyler
could have you know twice as many Rush
attempts as to and probably more past
steps than two as well in a far worse
Cardinals team right now it just has to
keep on you know putting the game in
kylo's hands sooner rather than later
with the way things are shaken out for
them
from at eight Bradley T Higgins or Jamal
Williams in the flex this is a good
problem to have I would Lane Jamal
Williams though assuming DeAndre Swift
is going to be out I guess you can't
assume that though with Higgins playing
tonight oh man you are loaded dude if
you got T Higgins has a potential bench
play I would probably actually just
start T Higgins tonight it's enough of a
risk enough of a drop off and you have
such a good option in the first place I
do think T Higgins is going to be worth
it there I will say though if you're
able to
um put T Higgins in your wide receiver
spot not the flex even if you're going
to start the other wide receiver just a
good move on Thursday in case your other
wide receiver you know gets hurt or
something like that in between now and
Sunday then you can still play Jamal
Williams if you play t Higgins in the
flex right now you're not going to have
that same flexibility from at Bert laws
mixing for CD lamb
that's a tough one that's a toss-up hey
if your roster like you need a wide
receiver I do think that's pretty fair
value unfortunately for mixing in this
Bengals Run game they've just been
terrible this year I mean 27th and EPA
per Run play but mixing actually has the
most expected PPR points at the position
they've been more willing to give him
the two-minute offense even though
samaje piran is usually coming on the
field in the obvious pass situation so
straight up I think I would take mixing
like a pick or two ahead of CD lamb you
know if we were redrafting for the rest
of the season right now but just in
terms of like I'm guessing you kind of
need wide receiver help I think that's a
fair running back to give up in order to
get a guy that should be a wide receiver
one again literally as early as next
week if Dak Prescott's going to be back
in week five
from at Harry cybert do I start Pollard
or Madre Stevenson in the flex gonna be
Roman J Stevenson unfortunately both the
Cowboys and Patriots offenses last year
ranked first and sixth in points much
worse at the moment again Cooper Rush is
you know surpassing expectations still
not in offense that we should be
expecting to score more than 20 or so
points more weeks to not so Stevenson we
needed so many things to go right for
him to have this role but they have
James White retired JJ Taylor and
Captain Harris became non-factors here
on the practice squad and even Pierre
strong the guy they also drafted in the
fourth round he's been dealing with the
shoulder injury and not getting on the
field so Ty Montgomery is on IR with an
ankle injury so finally the Patriots are
using a two running back committee
ramandre Stevenson is right there at
Damon Harrison the early down role and
he's taken almost all the pass down
snaps so Madre Stevenson I mean right
now we just again having Brian Hoyer
likely under Center is tough to be over
too overly High under Madre Stevenson
but he really has the utilization of a
borderline rb1 so fire him up as a rock
solid rb2 unfortunately Tony pollards is
still working too much behind Zeke to
take him over someone like that
from at Raymond Dakota it's a time to
trade Eckler
I think it's time to treat him more so
as a low end rb1 I mean if you look at
it this year in quarters one through
three so first 45 minutes of the game
Austin necklace is a PPR rb31 and
quarter four he's the rb3 and that
doesn't mean that the Chargers you know
are just finally getting right in the
fourth quarter and are giving the ball
to their best player it's been a matter
of the Chargers really losing by
multiple touchdowns in the fourth
quarter and just you know digging and
dunking it down to Eckler a time and
time again when the defenses are happy
to give up that was completions so hey
garbage points you know they count the
same as points in the first quarter in
fantasy football style points don't
matter I get it and if Eckler is going
to catch the 117 passes that he's on
Pace to catch this season then okay I
could see him you know still coming
through in full PPR but we have too much
usage out of Sony Michelle and Joshua
Kelly to feel overly confident about
that that's the problem with Eckler guys
he's not running well and he's not even
getting enough Rush attempts to overcome
him not running well so it's not that
Sonya Michelle or Joshua Kelly in it of
themselves are causing a big issue but
when you combine them when you make the
it's a three running back backfield
whereas almost all of last year was only
two it has been problematic for Austin
Eckler I just don't want to sell him at
his bottom so try to wait for one more
big game and then if you want to try to
sell them as a top five pick that a lot
of people maybe still believe him to be
that's the move
from at Jordan Montes Breece Hall cam
Acres or Damien Harris that is a very
tough call three guys I think are all in
the rb3 range I'm gonna lean cam Acres
uh this week I think we can finally get
back there briefs Hall I think we could
see the same thing we saw last year with
Michael Carter and even uh Ty Johnson
for the stretches when Zach Wilson
missed time Mike White and Joe Flacco
came in two quarterbacks that don't run
around anywhere near as much as what
Zach Wilson does and unfortunately
that's going to really hurt Breece
Hall's ability to rack up those passes
Damon Harris you know he's basically
reminders Stevenson without the pass
down role and then this Patriots offense
right now I'm not expecting him to have
too many opportunities to be putting up
touchdowns cam makers really
back-to-back weeks now has beaten Daryl
Henderson in the touch battle and good
note from Sean McVay he confirmed that
even though Acres did fumble out the
goal line last week he said Acres would
have been right back out there if they
needed him they didn't because they just
had two kneel Downs on their next drive
after that but McVeigh confirmed
four-minute offense was going to be cam
makers he's out the doghouse great day
to be a cam Maker's owner finally took
till week four but I think we're in a
good spot again everyone
from at AWS Garrett Wilson London or
alave it's gonna be Chris alave for me
if Michael Thomas is going to be out of
the picture it's it's tough with these
injuries guys it is a London game so
often know in the morning but if Jameis
Winston is out and Michael Thomas is in
then I would lean with Drake London if
you know we do have Michael Thomas out
though then I think Chris lava is going
to have too much volume to be able to
turn away you know versus someone like
Drake London so good problem to have
though I mean Drake London and Chris
olave really should be starters in the
overwhelming majority of lineups if you
would just rather roll with London I
don't think that's egregious at all
from Matt Crusoe Aaron Jones and Terry
McLaren for Justin Jefferson and Damian
Pierce yes I'm making that trade uh 10
times out of 10 you're getting by far
the best player in Justin Jefferson like
Aaron Jones he's awesome but it's Aaron
Jones and AJ Dylan if you wanted to rank
them right next to each other in the rb2
range I don't think that you'd be
mistaken unfortunately we're seeing the
Packers give these guys Aaron Jones one
series basically AJ Dylan the next it's
not you know the Alvin Kamara role we
were hoping for with Aaron Jones taking
all the pass down work they're fine
thrown to AJ Dylan too which is great
for AJ Dylan managers I just think Aaron
Jones is someone that we need to get a
little more used to treating as that
borderline rb1 you know high-end rb2
whereas with Justin Jefferson again it's
more of a matter of when not if he
breaks out of this mini slump and then
when Damien Pierce was Tara mcclorn I
would call that a pretty near wash so
give me the Justin Jefferson side of
things
from at Mr penge selling or buying DK
Metcalf mention that brother we are
buying low all over the place on DK
Metcalf simple reasons and simple
reasoning here we know DK Metcalf is an
incredibly talented player that's been
proven time and time again during a
short career we also now know or at
least we have you know five eight games
worth of Geno Smith being an average to
honestly pretty great quarterback now
I'm not going to say that he's this
great quarterback because it still is a
small sample size but the reason why DK
Metcalf and Tyler Lockett were going so
late in fantasy football compared to
last year's was because of the
assumption that Geno Smith was by far
the worst quarterback in the league he
is not it's not like we don't have other
examples of wide receivers doing just
fine with you know bad quarterback play
we were happy to draft Brandon Cooks
Terry McLaren and guys like that way
ahead of DK Metcalf even though they
didn't have great quarterbacks because
we just had kind of our quarterback
rankings messed up in regards to Geno
Smith so Metcalf is on a team that can't
stop a nosebleed like they're going to
continue to allow a bunch of points on
on defense you know with some of the
injuries they've had there they're going
to throw the ball more accordingly and
the quarterback isn't as bad as we
thought DK Metcalf should only have more
big games here again maybe not this week
just because I think the Lions as we saw
against Justin Jefferson have a really
good game plan for taking away the wide
receiver one so I do think this could be
titled a locket week but in general DK
Metcalf seventh you know most PPR points
below expectation only a matter of when
not if he's gonna blow up and get back
to being the guy that we've seen you
know during the majority of a short
career and that is one of the more
talented wide receivers in the NFL so
that's gonna wrap up this edition of BR
fantasy thank you guys for tuning in
we're back each and every Thursday at 5
p.m Eastern I'm Ian Hardison until next
time take care everybody
[Music]
foreign